Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it.
Nobody else.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you by fresh books,
man.
Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners of this podcast and readers of mine love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices,
track your time,
and get paid very,
very quickly,
which suits the needs of a lot of freelancers,
a lot of [inaudible] and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit card and debit cards.
So all the things you buy automatically appear in your fresh books in the right
category,
so on and so forth.
Makes taxes easy,
makes invoices easy.
It makes your life easier.
And also,
in fact,
I'd recommend a pdf.
Uh,
they didn't ask me to read this part by the way.
They'd put the other pdf awhile back called breaking the time barrier subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week with a service business and the story in
that Ebook,
it's pdf is the short answer is really,
really good,
so I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
checking out,
but also why not test out freshbooks.
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
enter timferriss two rs and two ss in the how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very little tracking and it's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and tried out because it is a
very good product and I think you will find it simplifies your life.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you by Shopify.
I have known and loved Shopify just about forever.
Back in 2009 when they had something like eight or 10 employees,
now they have more than 2000 I helped them as an advisor to create the build a
business competition,
which is now the world's largest entrepreneurship competition and many readers
of my blog,
first time business owners have ended up making millions and millions of dollars
each,
many of them as side gigs to their full time jobs.
So the goal of the build a business competition is to get,
would be entrepreneurs to get off the couch and make things happen.
All you have to do is open a store on Shopify and starts selling and you can
join in July or after July to be eligible to win.
What does winning mean?
You have to be one of the top performers,
top sellers in a given category and the prize,
the reward,
an exclusive opportunity to learn from mentors and experts.
And in the past that has happened at places like the Gatsby castle where we had
Tony Robbins and Daymond John and Seth Goden and so on,
or a Necker island,
which is Sir Richard Branson's private island.
It's nuts and super,
super fun.
I'm also involved,
so there's a special offer for people listening to this show.
Go to shopify.com forward slash Tim and sign up for a free 30 day trial.
You will get all sorts of exclusive free video courses to help you along and to
get started,
including how to start a profitable drop shipping business with Corey Ferera.
You will also get some goodies from me that's all free.
It's all exclusive to people who are listening to this podcast,
so check it out.
shopify.com forward slash Tim and remember to sign up for the free 30 day trial.
Why?
Hello there.
This is Tim Ferriss team of [inaudible].
Hey,
you tongue breaker of chains,
mother of dragons.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Where does my job always to deconstruct world class performers of many,
many different varieties,
pulling out the lesson strategies,
habits,
et Cetera,
that you can apply and test in your own life.
My guest today is none other than the comedian's comedian bill burr at bill burr
on Twitter,
Please say hello.
Many of you know him as a standup comedian.
Of course,
his youtube clips have followed me around the planet as has his podcast.
He is one of the funniest humans alive.
I mean he loses his audience sometimes on purpose because making them laugh is
not enough of a challenge and then he'll wheel them back in and get them back on
his side.
And he has been requested for this podcast for many years.
Rolling Stone has called him quote the undisputed heavyweight champ of rage
fueled humor and quote.
And when we finally got on the same stage to have a conversation and do this,
he did not disappoint.
So in this very wide ranging conversation and bill and I go all over the place,
we talked about how he found his way into standup comedy,
uh,
why he enjoys going for an encore after he's been booed,
how he started as a squeaky clean comedian and then ended up where he is now.
Just quite,
quite different.
Hell learning,
conserve as therapy,
the importance of enjoying success and much more.
This interview comes from my TV show,
fearless with fear,
the less,
less in parentheses because the objective is to learn to fear less,
not to be fearless,
not possible in which I interview world class performers.
That's probably my favorite Combo word onstage about how they've overcome doubt,
conquered fear,
and made their toughest decisions.
You can watch the entire first episode with illusionists David Blaine for
free@att.net forward slash fearless,
no parentheses,
so all one word,
att.net forward slash fearless the way you would usually spell it.
Highly recommend you check that out and to see all episodes.
You can get an undirect TV or you can go to direct TV now,
uh,
and I believe that's just direct TV now.com but direct TV Dot Comso d I r e c t
v.com and then click on direct.
Now we recorded about three hours of material on stage and only one hour was
used for TV.
That means this episode is almost entirely new content that did not appear on
TV.
So even if you saw that episode already,
you're going to get a lot more patented.
Bill Burns.
So please enjoy this wide ranging conversation with Mr. Bill.
Burn.
Welcome,
fearless.
I'm your host Tim Ferris.
And on this stage will be deconstructing world class performers to uncover the
specific tactics that they've used,
overcome doubt,
tackle hard decisions,
and ultimately succeed.
So imagine yourself all alone on stage in front of 14,000 people staring
directly at you.
For many of us,
probably most of us,
that'd be a complete nightmare.
But for my guest tonight,
it's just another day at the office.
The man you're about to meet is one of the most prolific and respected comedians
in the world.
He's done five hour long comedy specials,
host one of the most popular podcasts of all time and it's the cocreator and
star of the animated series.
F is for family.
Please welcome to the stage bill burr.
How are you?
How are you doing buddy?
I'm good,
I'm good.
Do you ever get booed?
You got to come back.
If there's an encore,
you got to go back.
I think you got to go back.
So I wave and I remember there was this kid came running up cause I trashed all
of the teams cause the Phillies had won a world series yet they look like two
years away from it at that point.
And I just remember this kid was like,
was,
was yelling at me,
he's just going to just go down.
He's going,
fuck you.
Fuck you for giving me the finger yelling.
Fuck you.
When I was standing there,
he was like a 30 yards away.
I just kept going.
I kept going.
What,
what?
They started going,
I literally just be like giving me the finger.
Like I don't know where it is.
I just kept going.
One,
I literally got the keys like hopping mad by the end.
He was,
he was jumping up.
Fuck you.
I can't,
I can't.
I remember I was standing next to opion we were just laughing going like,
how dumb is this kid?
So,
um,
but then I was,
I was mortified afterwards because I thought,
um,
you know,
cause I knew like a lot,
a lot of stuff was coming up on,
you know,
people who are having phones,
they had cameras and I was just going,
you know,
everyone's going to see me get booed.
This is going to be embarrassing.
I didn't know how it was going to play.
I just thought,
um,
that people weren't going to understand it.
We first connected and started texting because we know Dave [inaudible] who was
an amazing professional drummer.
Yeah.
And teacher and the teacher is just incredible.
He is a
great t shirt for you guys who are looking for teachers to buy and it says,
uh,
let's say more slowly.
Once again,
something like that.
It's slow down,
slow down and I think it says Pete or do it gate or do it again on the back.
And so he'll just get sick of sat in the same thanks.
We just point to one side of his shirt.
How did you get into drum it?
Y and why drumming?
Ah,
how did I get a drum?
I guess everyone was in the music,
you know,
where I grew up and everything.
And um,
I loved music,
but I didn't stop playing drum set.
It was almost like 20 years old.
I started really late but,
and the reason for that was I was working in a warehouse and I came from a jock
towns.
Everybody played sports,
you know,
pond hockey and all that.
So I did a lot of that stuff.
And like I liked music but there's only a couple of kids that play guitar and I
wasn't around it like I didn't think was possible.
I thought what I was watching people doing on TV,
I just didn't think he could do it.
And then I started working in this warehouse and there was kids my age and they
were from a different town that was more like kids put together bands and stuff
and they were coming in and like the songs I liked,
they could play it.
And I was like,
wow,
that's amazing.
So I started playing guitar and I just didn't have the patience for it.
And I think the thing about drumming was the steep sport background where it was
like a real physical thing that,
that it kind of came into play and I just started,
I just started playing and um,
I played for like six,
seven years,
um,
in,
during somewhere.
During that time I started playing,
I started doing standup and I moved to New York.
And your neighbors don't mind if you're strumming a guitar.
You can't like play drums in a one bedroom apartment without pissing everybody
off.
So I kind of stopped for like five years before I got back into it.
Yeah.
I grew up on long island.
I feel like we have the,
we don't have a tough accent.
It's just a bad accent.
Yeah,
I think it was a,
it's a lot like the show we do efforts of family with where it was just like the
parents just sent you outside and some days you had good days,
some days she had bad days,
sometimes you just ran into bigger kids and they would just beat the shit out of
you for no reason.
I just was thinking,
I remember them putting in a pool one time and they would just,
they were like,
you know,
whatever the hell it is when they're smoothing out the concrete.
And this older kid dared me to throw right into it.
So I,
I wanted his approval and I just took this big rock and this guy would just
smoothing it out and just throw it down.
This guy almost killed me,
killed me.
So that's back when you could almost kill a kid.
And it was,
it wasn't a problem.
It was no cell phone.
Video was all your word against theirs.
So
I think a lot of the reasons why I started doing standup was I just thought,
okay,
I'm going to get onstage,
show people that I'm a funny guy and people will stop fucking with me.
Like that was basically,
and then they,
and then that was,
that was,
I remember thinking then everything's going to fall into place.
I meet the girl of my dreams,
I make my money,
I'll get my whatever the hell I want a house.
And so I only worked on getting better as a comedian.
And then by the time I got to my mid thirties,
like being a comedian was like 600 miles down the road and everything else was
that the starting blocks and like literally like social interactions.
I kept messing up relationships.
I mean I was 36 I was still sleeping,
sleeping on a Futon,
um,
in what they call was a one bedroom apartment,
which was bullshit because I met the woman who lived upstairs.
We have the exact same apartment and hers was a studio.
They just slammed a wall and a mine.
And um,
yeah,
so I remembered like those,
there was like a three year period of like,
I was in a full on depression and I was so detached.
I didn't,
I wasn't even,
I wasn't even aware of it.
When,
what,
what was the age roughly on that?
Oh,
I dunno.
It was like the early two thousands,
whatever that may,
late nineties,
early two thousands.
It might've been a five,
six year.
I can't remember.
I didn't worry about making it.
I didn't worry about how am I going to make money.
I didn't work.
I just like,
I'm doing this.
And when Billy got off stage,
I mean it was the end of the night,
I was like going like,
who do I call for open mics?
Like how do I do this?
And I remember he wrote down,
Rita and I read a choice who was a,
she used to book it and uh,
she was like back then,
like one of the big characters,
like used to always run into a comedy club.
So I used to call in to do open mikes and uh,
I remember she used once she got to know me and she thought I was kind of funny.
I call up and be like,
hey,
hey Rita,
it's a bill Burra I'd like to Joe doing it and it should go.
No,
no,
no bill,
you call me and you say,
Rita,
this is open.
Miker Bill Burr.
I was,
she was always breaking balls.
So I would always laugh and I would do it.
And she was kind of like a test,
like if you had like a sense of humor about yourself.
And I gradually like work my way in
to doing stand up.
You know,
I remember one time I did a show,
I've told this before,
but I did this show.
I was,
I was uh,
seeing this woman when I was in New York and,
and I'm here.
She came over and I was making a dinner,
whatever.
And then I had a spot at the comic strip,
which where I was living was right around the corner.
So I said,
I got to go run to a spot.
And during the week,
I mean,
you know,
she asked me what the,
what are those spots pay and they would like the comic strip was hilarious.
It was like $5,
$8 seven and it's basically just going up there trying out material.
And I went up there and,
um,
I tried out new material and it worked and I was psyched.
And I came home and I've finished like cooking the dinner or whatever and they
was making,
I can't remember what was making an a,
I did this stupid dance in the kitchen and she was laughing and I was dancing
cause I had this new material,
I was excited.
And then she got like this,
uh,
she got to sad look on her face.
God,
I dance that bad.
Like what,
what's the matter,
right.
And she goes,
no,
she goes,
I just wish I had a job where I got paid $8.
I came home and danced in a kitchen
and I never forgot that.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I didn't even,
I didn't even think that cause I got this weird thing about money where I,
I want to have it so I'm not broke,
but I don't give a shit about it.
But I also don't want to have debt,
so I don't overextend myself,
but I don't,
uh,
I don't give a shit about it.
Like I will,
I will pay extra to not go through the process.
Like I can't even act like I don't use like,
you know,
frequent flyer miles.
Like my wife signed me up for him,
but I don't use them ever because I didn't want to go through the fucking,
you know,
logging in and all of a sudden I'm working for American Airlines and I got to
work for these fucking people.
Like I'll buy my own ticket.
I don't want to do this.
Yeah,
I won't cancel shit.
Like I got like gym memberships,
I've never canceled cause I'm not,
cause I'm not going through going on that stupid thing.
And if you want to do this,
press one,
if you want to do that press too.
Like I got,
I dunno,
like my free time.
I,
I cherish it and I'm not like going to fucking,
I'm not,
I'm not going to be laying on my death bed one time,
just thinking about how many hours I spent on the phone going,
person,
operator,
Parson,
fuck you.
Like,
I know I don't want to do that.
So,
um,
I would rather pay the,
I'd rather pay the extra charts yet.
So a little bit later I want to pull up the,
not caring about money examples that I have found most personally am using,
which are actually from your podcast.
So we'll get to those.
Okay.
But,
uh,
at the time said,
if you can just place us,
when were you working in your dad's office and maybe you could describe what
your dad did?
Early nineties to mid nineties,
I was working in a,
um,
my work in a dental office and I had been laid off from the warehouse with the
guy all coked up.
Right.
But my car was paid off,
thank God.
And I was living at home,
so I was kind of living like this little existence to like three months.
And my dad started,
uh,
working with this other guy,
went into practice with them and I need,
he needed some,
you know,
I think it was just sick of watching me being around the house.
So nepotism kicked in and next thing you know,
I've got a lab coat and I'm standing next to him,
handed him all the shit as he's taking teeth out and stuff.
And I had to get past the gross factor of that.
And uh,
then I learned how it pulled up models and stuff and takes x rays.
And I was actually,
I was halfway decent at it,
but I knew that,
you know,
for half a second I thought maybe,
I would do this.
But what was funny was I had to call my father,
Dr. Berger.
I couldn't call him dad in front of a patient because that would be weird.
Like,
Hey dad.
So I had to keep it professional.
And uh,
when I worked there was around the time when I started doing standup and what
sucked.
I was still living at home so he knew because at the end of the night to be away
working tonight and I would have like a,
I'd have like a Gig in Maine live in,
in Massachusetts and I went for free and I would drive up there and maybe like
five,
10 bucks gas money and I would drive all the way up and my dad would have like
seven o'clock patients and shit.
Like he worked like a lunatic.
Like from seven to seven.
He would side book root canals like on Molders,
which is three,
you know,
nerve involvements.
We'd be,
we'd like numb up a guy and then we go in the other room and like,
and he didn't give a shit too.
Like I don't,
one time some homeless guy came in,
he was like,
I finally got a lunch because you'd never get a lunch with them.
This guy came in,
you know,
he was,
substance abuse and he was all,
you know,
and all these other guys I noticed with just give a medicine.
They would leave,
my dad would be like,
and just get them in there and blah blah.
And I was like pissed and have we had doctor by what the fuck?
Like can we just get this guy,
you know?
And he just goes,
look,
he goes,
I can't go home tonight.
No one,
there's some guy in pain and I didn't do anything.
[inaudible]
did you get material for,
for your comedy from that experience?
So yeah,
big test.
I read that you had dental comedy early and I don't know dental comedy is,
Oh yeah,
no,
no.
I had all of it.
I owe that.
My Dad used to like,
he used to set me up because he knew that I swear to God if I had like a,
like a late show,
then he would go extra fast.
He'd just go x gimme that gimme that deal.
Christ,
but you're out to lunch.
He would start giving me shit in front of the patient.
I used to tell him like,
like dad,
you can't do that type of stuff.
And like he,
he wasn't like that,
but I got a lot of it out of like patients.
Like I remember this guy came in,
uh,
I used to work totally squeaky clean,
totally clean.
Cause I didn't want to offend anybody because I didn't want to get heckled cause
I was still this really shy person.
Right.
So I remember this guy came in one time and like his teeth were all rotting out
and I just remember he said something like,
I like doc,
you know,
I don't want to stay with the problem is,
I,
I brushed my teeth almost every day.
Right?
That's what he said.
So
my punchline to that was like,
oh yeah,
well do you wipe your ass almost every time you take a shit.
So for a while I started closing on that joke and I would work totally squeaky
clean going up there looking like Ron Howard never.
He's like,
Oh look at this wholesome guy.
And then out of nowhere I would just end with,
yeah,
you wipe your ass so much every time you take a shit.
And they'd be like,
dude,
I'm
like dude,
what's going on?
I had no idea what I was doing.
I actually was a prop back for a second where I had one problem.
For whatever reason.
You're not allowed to have props in comedy and acting.
It's fine.
I have no idea.
Right.
So we had this dental mass,
like when you really had some gnarly shit going on,
they had these plastic things.
It looked like a welder's shield but it's all plastic and we just,
I'll spare you the details and stuff is flying at you.
So I used to bring that and I would take it out after I would do all the dental
material and be like,
yeah,
my job so bad.
Like I have to wear this at work.
And I would just put it on and I had no joke and I would put it on and they'd
sort of chuckle and be like waiting for the joke.
And then behind the mass,
like almost like muffled.
I'd be like
taken away and I put it back in my little duffle bag and I'd walk away.
It was just,
it was horrible.
How do you know when something is close and when something is done?
Like A,
when you're working on a joke or a piece of writing,
how do you know when something's done?
Well,
I think when I'm on a tour and none of the jokes are done until I start getting
sick of them,
then I'm like,
all right,
I need to record these and document these because they're going to start
becoming not funny because they're starting to feel like a job to tell them I'm
sick of this joke and all that.
God,
I want to do this joke and this is one so long and I might not think that
anymore.
And those things,
sometimes those things just drop away and you never record them or anything.
So I'd say it's like that when you bond that first time,
was that a Kelly's the third,
third gig chases you did your research is try to help him find that one.
I must have told that on another podcast.
So the good team helping me,
magic elves in the back as well.
The way you got to cover that camera up on your flat screen and on your laptop.
That's actually really,
that's true.
You,
they tried to see what you're watching and shit.
If you bang your wife.
So I want to talk about last Tuesday night
when you,
uh,
I imagine the drive back after that Gig was very different from uh,
from the Motley Crue.
They're mortified,
mortified.
How did you,
what did you do to get yourself back on the horse for the V for the next Gig?
I mean,
would you say to yourself before you got on stage to the next time?
Because a lot of people will like fall off.
They don't get back.
Oh well I fell off a lot of things that need to get back on.
But like I also always knew I knew if I was good at something or if I wasn't
like,
you know what I mean?
Like,
as much as I love playing drums and everything,
I went to the music store enough times and saw an eight year old get on a drum
kit and I'd be like,
dude,
like I would pay you to take the,
it's like I just didn't have it.
Like it's a hobby.
It's something I enjoyed doing,
but I would never subject anybody to it on a professional level.
So,
um,
this happens to me a lot with my add is I went down that road and I forgot the
question.
Question was,
which is fine by the way.
Uh,
the question was how did you get back on the horse?
Would you say to yourself before getting back on stage?
It never dawned on me not to do it again.
Right.
And you are committed to the next gig.
All the other social shit that mortified me.
I just stayed away from it.
But that thing was like,
I don't think I had another might be.
I just was like,
you knew,
you know what's going to happen.
It's like you're riding a motorcycle,
you know,
one of these days you're going to go down.
You just hope you're going to live.
You talked about some dark periods earlier,
I'm forgetting the exact timeline,
but what precipitated that?
Yes.
He said it was a couple of years and for people who don't know and I almost off
myself,
uh,
during a year off from college.
So it's like I've had some,
some battles.
What motive we what,
what,
how are we going to do it?
You know what?
So this is a good question and I'll tell you why.
I'm not going to give an answer because it was a really good plan.
It was a plan that would minimize guilt or self blaming on the part of my
family.
It was really well thought through.
I had everything specked out and so for the right hip line in the woods and it
was so mostly,
yeah.
Involve some porcupines a little bit of cure.
All right.
Yeah,
it was very complex.
Hard to replicate.
But uh,
yeah,
I wouldn't want people to copycat it if I,
if I put it out there.
But what,
what precipitated that period for you?
Um,
uh,
what does that mean?
What came before that
triggered it?
Like what led
usually weatherman language.
My bad.
I don't know why.
It just comes out of me sometimes.
Uh,
yeah.
What led,
what led to it?
Like what triggered is going into that fight?
Have you laughing?
Didn't know what it meant either.
Thank you.
I was,
it was,
I was just going full speed towards a wall that I,
you know,
cause I thought I was normal,
well adjusted and even though I knew I had like a crazy temper,
I had this period where I just was really just like,
you know,
I would be what you needed me to be.
Yeah.
And like I really had like,
I was friends with everybody.
Right.
Which is not a real thing.
Yeah.
If you're being who you are,
I would just,
I would adjust my shit so I wouldn't cause any friction.
So that wouldn't be,
you know,
any like,
the Shit I dealt with coming up,
I had enough of people screaming and yelling.
I had enough of fighting and all that stuff that I would just adjust my behavior
so then we,
we would just be smooth.
And,
um,
I just think using that as a game plan eventually you just going to use,
so going to spin away from who the hell you are.
Um,
that I think that,
you know,
and also just focusing on staying up and not other areas of my life.
I think then that's when the anger and all of that stuff started to come up and
then I kind of went like this completely different person and I really started
snapping about nothing for a good 12 years.
And uh,
I think just somewhere in there,
somewhere in there,
I mean maybe I was always like depressed,
but I didn't realize it.
I think I just didn't realize it.
And somewhere along the line,
you know,
one of the umpteen thousand poor women that ever came across me,
like one of them finally told me to go to therapy and I went there thinking
like,
yeah,
I'm fine if blah,
blah,
blah.
Then you start telling story and it was all this shit that I knew that happened
but was just hovering.
Yep.
It just saw it.
It's just over here and you're just going around in life.
And then all of a sudden when you start talking about it,
it's you say it out loud,
it's like,
oh,
that's a real thing.
Oh,
that really did happen to me.
It's like,
and then you started thinking like,
wow,
I'm pretty fucked up.
Hey and I'm not here.
Yeah,
I'm really not happy.
Like I think I really started getting conscious of what my brain was telling me
and what my,
if my brain was like a friend,
I would like be like,
yeah,
dude,
we can't do this.
You're just,
well,
I'm in
me out,
man.
I mean,
Jesus Christ.
Do you ever see the light,
the fuck?
You know?
So then fortunately I wasn't like clinically,
so I didn't need any,
any medicine.
All I needed was a,
I just needed to,
I just became aware of it
and I'd be like,
all right,
well there's that thought.
Do you want to have that thought or you want to go to the gym?
I got back into playing drums,
which was a great thing.
And,
um,
then I also said I just stopped giving a shit about making it in a way where
it's just like,
you know what?
Forget this.
I'm just going to do what I do.
Cause I went through that whole period like you know,
I know.
I mean when are you guys trying to make it out here?
You just go through that period where you're just like,
oh they,
they,
they like guys with the,
you know,
whatever blue button down shirts and you wearing the blue button down shirts and
people who talk about this,
they like it my time.
It's gone from the tail end of the sport coat guy into the grunge guy into the
AllSeen into the whole like whatever that period was where guys in their
thirties acted like they were 14 and they were awkward and just,
you know,
the Hoodie like that.
My wife called up my,
uh,
which you call them Ma,
not baby men or something.
Man.
Boys,
man and boys,
the streets,
she called them and I don't know,
I'm just like awkward.
Like that was just this default thing.
Yeah.
It's like,
oh great.
Now I have to hold up both ends of the conversation.
So I really just,
those people I really just,
I kinda got hostile with,
I was just like,
well when you get over with that,
you know and you can fucking talk to me.
Yeah,
you are awkward.
This is weird.
And I also thought a lot of people know,
but a lot of people that do that,
it's also what's a passive aggressive thing to come in and fucking steal focus
and we all have to deal with how awkward you are and make sure you're okay.
It's like fuck you dude,
you're in your thirties figure this out.
I never forget one time I was in a green room in New York,
I was living in La and I met an old friend and we were talking about the old
days about when we,
I remember this guy,
I remember that night when this happened,
we having a great time and then was younger comics and they will listen.
And then some people who actually were in the tail end of the stories we have in
this great time.
And then this woman comes in comedian and she was like socially awkward and she
didn't know how to like get into it.
So we're all,
yeah,
you haven't,
we're all laughing,
everything.
And she walked right into the middle of the circle.
I swear to God,
she just walked in.
I'm like,
hello,
hello.
And she was like mocking saying hello.
Yeah.
But then totally stole all the focus and everyone's just like,
oh Whoa,
wait,
y'all riding and all the fun one out of the room.
And then everyone was dealing with her and then she left and I said to my free
to go do what the fuck.
What the fuck was that?
That was like,
that was some rude shit.
We were having a great time.
And like if you don't have to say fucking alone,
learn how to do it,
they'll come in and take the whole thing away.
Just ruin this thing.
And that was the last time.
That was the last time I was like,
fuck these awkward people.
Well,
like if you're really,
if you really are,
I don't want to like bully people.
I don't want to
please stop me if they really are socially awkward and stuff like that,
I'll work with you.
But if you've just didn't braced right,
I'm awkward now.
The world has to deal with it.
If that's your shit.
Yeah,
go.
go fuck yourself.
So we're all,
we're all,
we also have a clip that will pull up in a minute from F is for family.
That might,
I don't know.
Also now that I've seen all the episodes and now that you're telling me a lot of
these stories,
I can see where I think a lot of them came from there.
There's one clip that will pull up in a little bit.
I'm not going to her just right now,
but,
uh,
what have you found to help
get you out of a depressive period?
You mentioned exercise a for instance.
I mean,
I've,
I've found drummers in general be very happy people,
I don't know if they're happy and then they end up jumping or if it's because of
the physical aspect of just going animal on a drum kit.
It's awesome.
It's a great feeling.
I also had,
uh,
played the drums in college,
but not very good at all.
But that was my experience.
It was,
it was like a,
it alleviated a lot of these darker spots.
Is there anything else that you've found particularly helpful?
Yeah,
I just do shit.
I just get up and do something that day and it's literally like,
I'll,
I will like,
you know,
I'll go on you like to cook and stuff.
So I'll go on youtube and I'll see somebody,
uh,
you know what I did recently?
Um,
who's the guy from Hell's kitchen?
I was,
uh,
Gordon Ramsay.
Yeah.
Dude.
He's got this video,
like the sickest scrambled egg you're ever going to make it and your life.
It's insane.
And,
um,
I just remember watching it and I was just like,
I'm going to fucking make that thing and uh,
cause I have the free time,
like as a comedian,
like I can do it.
And I went out and I bought all the ingredients and all that type of stuff.
And,
uh,
that's,
that's what I do and I've,
I,
or I'll learn something.
Um,
um,
you know,
but I do have my hobbies like cooking and playing drums and a few other things
that I do.
And it's just like,
I try to have like that moment in the day,
um,
like learn something or go somewhere like in what,
but working out is a,
is a,
is a big thing because that's a big thing.
How did your goals change if they did from when you're trying to force fit
yourself?
Like what was the kind of pinnacle that you had in mind for making it to after
golf?
Me Coming up,
it was all about having an Hbo Special Cause Hbo specials,
those,
those were the best comics.
That's all the great guys that I saw coming up you've got on HBO is totally
uncensored.
And they were the home for that.
And unfortunately when I got into it,
um,
you know,
write them like early nineties.
By the mid nineties,
they just stopped doing it for like 10 years.
And um,
so I don't,
I,
that was,
that's when I kind of felt rudderless because when HBO stopped doing their
specials,
I didn't know what to do.
And then what,
what comedy central started doing the half hours they,
you,
you are,
um,
the fact that they had commercials,
they basically,
I think it's eight minutes each hour.
So they're automatically going to take 16 minutes out or eight minutes out of a
half hour.
And then they also,
they would stay,
would beep out the curses with like the worst,
most archaic,
like big pape so it really,
and they wouldn't just fade it down and come back up.
So um,
I remember watching specials and just thinking that was really distracting.
So once again,
I work clean.
So if you watch my first half hour of comedy central,
I worked totally clean.
Um,
and I gave them,
I gave them the least amount of material that I could because I just looked at
it cause those guys doing like,
all right,
here's a half,
you know,
it's a half hour then we're only gonna use 22 minutes.
They would,
they they would do is they do 40.
So then you had this guy who you didn't know,
you didn't approve of,
is now going to hack 40 minutes down to 22.
What is he going to do?
Exactly.
So I was like,
immediately I was like,
wow,
fuck that.
What kind,
what's the least you can do?
And they see at least you can mount of time you can do is like 25 or 26.
And I did exactly that.
So the worst you could do was butcher for of it out,
but the rest of it was going to look good.
So I was happy with it.
And um,
you know,
it was just kind of doing stuff like that,
but it still wasn't what I wanted because it wasn't me that that half hour that
I did that was me,
like just kind of doing an extended Letterman spot where I was working totally
clean.
And,
but it wasn't until HBO came back and did the half hours and I did those,
that uh,
I actually got to do,
it was the first time people got to see me,
you know,
not in a club.
They were at home and they got to see that this is what I do and it,
you know,
and that was the same time I got on the opiate Anthony show and they all kind of
came out at the same time.
It was the first time I went to a club and it was sold out and people were there
to see me,
which was a whole other level of pressure and use.
It used to be yes.
[inaudible].
Up
until then it was people coming to the club because that's what they did.
They had nothing else to do like,
oh,
it's good on the comedy club.
And you had to prove to them that you were funny.
And I just remember thinking like,
imagine if they came to see me,
how much easier this would be.
I didn't realize the other pressure was like,
no,
we saw that.
So we're expecting at least that if not better.
And then it's like,
oh man.
Um,
so that took me like a good three months of that there was a new kind of
nervousness experienced to get over of,
of people expecting like,
yeah,
we're here to see you.
We like what you do.
Don't ruin this.
What was the first special,
um,
the first half hour or not the comedy central,
but the first time you can be yourself.
Oh,
that was the HBO half hour that I did.
And um,
that was in two thousand five thousand five stone.
Remember April,
2005 came out in September.
Has,
is there anything since then,
and then,
and this is an assumption on my part,
which is dangerous,
but did you feel like you had summited the mountain at that point?
Did you feel like you'd arrived?
No,
I felt that somewhere in like 2009,
2010 by then and I'd done a couple of hours.
I've done my second hour for Netflix,
which became the new HBO as far as just totally uncensored.
And,
um,
I remember,
I think I bought a house at that point.
I bought a house.
Right.
And still,
you know,
people didn't really niche following in that and I said to my wife,
I was just like,
I know you're not supposed to say this,
but I made it cause this is sickness in this business of like,
no man,
if you think you made it and then then you're going to relax.
Yeah.
And it's all going to go away.
So like,
oh so I'm never going to be happy.
I tell Dick Jokes and I just bought a house.
I made it.
Yeah.
So
I didn't want to,
um,
I didn't want to be that guy that is doing well.
It's like,
oh well what about the next thing?
Like the,
those,
those debt,
that sickness.
Just the Greyhound chasing the rabbit.
The rabbit.
Yeah.
Performance or driven.
People can have this sickness of like,
it's just,
you know,
it's just like you can't even enjoy it.
It's like what's the next thing?
I mean I know guys that like they have like they accomplish something and as
their,
right as they're getting right to the peak,
this depression hits them cause they were like,
then what?
And then what am I going to do?
And then this is over.
And then,
then I got nothing and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
Hey,
can you just fucking have a beer up here with like,
we did this,
you know,
can we enjoy this for a second?
Did you keep,
did you continue doing therapy after those initial sessions that you mentioned?
I did it for a few years and then one day it just dawned on me that I just kind
of just talking in circles in here and it's just like,
bad shit's going to always happen to me and what am I going to keep coming in
here?
And I'm moaning about it.
Like,
what point am I going to grow up and kind of not need,
not need this?
And I'm not trying to say that you're weak if you go there,
but I just hit this point where,
uh,
I was,
I was like,
hi.
You know,
all of that shit happened.
it happened,
right?
And it definitely affected who I am.
But now I'm not going to be like lashing out of people.
I'll be like,
oh,
I do this because of that.
A little,
a little bit of that.
But I what I did,
you know,
at some point it'd be like if somebody is teaching you how to fix a car,
at some point you got to try to fix it yourself.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You can't keep going into the annoyed turn right here.
What,
how I do this.
Right.
So I just became like that.
So now I kind of,
um,
you know,
I kind of self therapy myself.
It's cheaper.
So you mentioned the,
uh,
I guess delusion maybe if always chasing the next thing and never being
satisfied with where you are.
The other worry that I've heard a lot from friends of mine who are comedians is
that if they do therapy or meditation or fill in the blank to tone down some of
their tendencies,
that it will make them less funny.
Yeah.
Is that something he thought that was true?
Now,
it's not true,
but what it does is it gives you an insight into you as a human and then you
start,
you see people differently.
And it actually allowed me to,
um,
right,
like,
or think about characters and just notice shit with people that I never did
before.
Like I gotta I gotta thing with somebody who,
somebody,
anybody who does this,
when they're talking like I wasn't blah,
blah,
they're full of shit.
Not only,
not only
are they full of shit,
they have a complete inability to accept responsibility for anything they've
ever done.
I just recently told this to Jim Norton.
Um,
it was that publicist who backed over like those 12 people in like long island.
And then I remember she just,
she drove away and then she went to her house when she got to our house,
like the cops showed up and the lawyer met them in the driveway and was like,
um,
yeah,
she'll come down tomorrow and blah,
blah,
blah.
And they left.
And I remember thinking like,
you can fucking do that.
I didn't know he could do that.
So she was of course vilified and in the next day in the paper,
they had this picture of her and she was like talking to the meeting.
She was like,
Eh,
she had her hand like that.
It's like you fucking backed over 11 people.
I'll go with you that,
that can happen,
that you can't see that but you left.
You fucking left.
Yeah,
get the fuck Outta here.
So I've noticed that and I remember,
so you start picking up on that.
I remember what time this comic did some passive aggressive shit to him.
I called him out on and he immediately went with the two hands,
the chest.
I'm like,
that's the kind of guy that went back over 11 people and drive away.
So I wouldn't have noticed that if I didn't go to therapy.
And I've also noticed like,
um,
you know,
like,
I like,
yeah,
I talked to myself a lot about like going,
you know,
like getting into it with people and screaming and yelling and then I'll drive
away and be like,
Hi Bill,
how did that go?
You know,
and then try to see how they are.
How you know,
if I was wrong in it,
like they will write,
you know,
that's somebody's mom.
You just yelled at her like,
what's wrong with you?
You're like,
I really had like a,
like really a hair trigger kind of thing.
So it's something that um,
you know,
working on my temper,
I really try to,
I really like,
especially lately because you know,
I was making my wife like on pins and needles because it wasn't like I was
flipping out over anything.
Like I fucking hate these things,
whatever.
This,
the second it came out and I saw this,
whatever,
this is,
this pad,
I bet I hate these.
I hate these six.
I can't stand them.
They don't make my life easier.
If they're a nightmare,
they're intrusive,
you know,
and my,
I can't stand.
So I flip out about them and like,
um,
I saw,
I think recently this politically active comedian was sitting there talking.
It was trying to get people to vote and like this oddly like bullying way going
like,
you know this is going to be an app out there that's going to say,
you know whether you voted or not and they're not going to know whether you
voted and who you voted for,
but they're going to know that you voted so you can't basically bullshit people
anymore.
I just was watching it the whole time going and like that's a good thing that
that level of private information because of this fucking APP.
I didn't say that.
You could say what I bought it or not.
That's what I,
that's what I hate about all of this shit.
Like I have a theory like,
like somewhere around 94 95 we should,
we should have stopped making new shit.
All they could,
they cured enough diseases.
Cards were fast enough you could gain,
no planes aren't any really faster than they were back then.
It was good.
But all of this shit now that like,
you know,
tape your cameras.
Yeah,
tape your cabin and stuff.
Look at Billy Bush.
Billy Bush got fired for some shit that happened in 2005 yeah,
this is fucking unbelievable.
And all he was doing as what an interview or does,
he was keeping the interviewee happy.
Right.
The Guy,
I go,
I just grab the pussy.
He's like,
Hey,
I grabbed some pussy.
What are we doing this for all you know,
the end of the interview when Trump left,
he could have been like,
what was it?
What's that guy like?
I think I was out of his mind.
He's talking about grabbing pussy.
She's fucking crazy.
Anyways,
who do we got next?
Matthew mcconaughey are at arrive.
What's going on?
You know,
it's just doing that for all you know.
That's
all he was doing and it was literally like,
that's what I hate about this shit is like you'd literally take two seconds and
somebody fucking life and you're like,
that's who you are.
That's you.
That that tweak is who you are.
That's what's in your heart and all of this shit.
I could,
friends of mine,
they've gotten like big shows,
SNL and stuff like that.
I think the one person,
they,
they go back to 2010 they went through six years of tweets to try and four,
we'll,
what was about this one?
Yeah.
It's like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Right?
Why didn't you start doing the podcast,
I guess?
Uh,
Bobby Kelly,
once again,
I was hanging in his apartment when we,
we used to live near each other in New York and he was just like,
dude,
you got to do this.
This is called the podcast.
I had no idea what it was.
You can say,
you know,
it's another way to connect with your fans.
And both me and M and all of my friends,
we,
we weren't the guys they were picking.
Yeah.
We just weren't the guys,
we weren't whatever they were going forward that we just never were the guys and
you know,
and yet we,
they all,
I be showcased,
they'd always put us on last because we would,
you know,
we,
we were really good at what we did,
but there was always like the,
you know,
whatever the hell it was they were looking for.
We were just,
we were the outcasts.
So,
um,
so any way to connect with your fans,
we had to do it and that was this new thing.
And I just liked doing it.
And at first I just,
I used to call it used to before I had like all the mixer and all that used to
call in this,
this service.
So I would just call up this phone number on my flip phone and I would just have
me be an airports and I would just be trashed and people and telling stories and
singing songs.
And at first I just did it for like seven minutes,
then it was 10 minutes,
then it became 20 than a half hour.
And then I started going like,
well,
you know,
yeah,
ask me some questions or I had this thing underrated,
overrated for a while and youtube video of the week.
And I just sort of built like a show around it.
And um,
and it just kind of became what it became.
Was it for shits and giggles or was there something,
no,
I want,
I want it to connect with fans.
You know,
it was a way to just,
just another thing to do.
And um,
but it was also,
uh,
I enjoyed it because there's other ways to connect with fans that I don't enjoy.
Like all those,
um,
those things you guys when you upload your pictures,
yeah,
I don't like those cause it says can we have access to,
to all your photos and it's like,
no,
you can have access to this photo so I don't do it,
you know,
so I just
don't do any of those.
But then there's other stuff that like this is the same thing.
It's like the mall thing again,
like does this fit into the wheelhouse of what I feel like I want to do and was
just something I liked doing.
So I just started doing it.
So between,
or I should say during the period of your specials and then getting all the way
to f is for family,
what were the,
what were the high points for you in that?
That entire thing?
The other question,
I didn't hurt that person.
Grown and out there like,
ah,
sorry,
we're getting down to the question.
Let's just see minus question.
Bear with me.
No,
I think I'm working on my material I think is acid as hardened from sitting down
so
we can,
we can go around.
Okay.
Here we go.
So from the,
from the point that you started doing your specialist up to f is for family,
were there any particular inflection points or experiences that set you on the
path that led you to where you are?
Formative experiences.
You don't think of Chappelle's show like breaking bad.
I mean you,
you have so much that you've done.
I'm just wondering if any stand out influenced my comedy or it just got me to
where I'm at both either.
All right.
Well getting me to where I'm at is like,
you know how long it took me to make.
It is like,
it's a bunch of people.
It's comics that I saw when I was in Boston.
People who gave me shots I'm getting in at the comic strip was a woman,
Amanda Schatz at MTV.
She saw me and Boston and then she was like,
I want you to,
I want to see you in New York.
And I couldn't get in at the comic strip.
I remember Ellucian going and I already have enough white guys,
blah,
blah.
And I remember,
I remember all these white guys used to get mad about this,
like reverse racism and they want to say all this type of shit.
And it's just like,
dude,
you know what he's saying?
There's like,
it's not even a dime a dozen.
we're a dime per 60 of us,
but if you're going to be another asshole coming in here talking about you
called the sac life,
he already has that.
So,
you know,
stop being a baby about it,
right?
Everything else is gravy for you as a white dude.
So,
um,
so I basically was like,
I remember thinking like,
all right,
this guy's,
oh,
I'm going to get in here.
I'm,
I don't know how,
but I'm going to get in here.
And she saw me.
And so she hooked me up with the showcase there.
Somehow I did.
Well,
I got passed there,
which led me to get into New York and then,
um,
through New York.
Just be in there.
I remember Dave Chappelle said some nice things to me one night.
I'm saying that basically a,
you're going to get there but the road that you're going is going to take
longer,
but when you,
when you get there,
you're going to have that stay in thing.
And I held onto that for years and when I would be playing some shit hole,
I was just like,
but Dave Chappelle said,
you know,
um,
but then it would just,
you know,
a lot of radio guys,
um,
uh,
Jim Norton get me in with opiate.
Anthea was huge.
Randy Bauman and Pittsburgh.
Cause like I would go to these markets and the guys that I really vibe with,
like they would give me the option to be like,
hey,
and rather than flying in Thursday morning for your through Sunday,
if you want to fly in Wednesday or Tuesday and just do radio the whole week,
um,
you know,
I'll help you pack the place.
And guys like Randy bombing in Pittsburgh and I would do that.
I would just come in,
have no shows Tuesday,
Wednesday,
and I would just do four hours of radio in the morning and do the whole morning
show and that do morning on Thursday and Friday,
just killing as hard as I could to,
you know,
get it like half full.
Maybe they don't have to pull the curtain.
And it was just all those types of things.
And um,
I guess,
uh,
I don't know.
I've been doing this shit for a long time,
so I'm trying to be a breaking bad.
Breaking bad was huge because
forever I wanted to play a guy like
that.
All right.
But back when I had my hair and stuff,
I look like Ron Howard.
So it was like day.
I was always the friend.
I was the nerd.
I just wasn't going to be that guy.
And I just always wanted to play a guy like Colby and they gave me a shot.
And,
um,
and then through that,
all of a sudden I got these other roles,
like,
you know,
once you get it on tape and they can see that you can do it,
then like,
oh,
we can do this and then people will take a shot on you.
So that,
that was a huge thing.
And,
um,
I'd say Mike binder with when I did black or white,
uh,
which became black and white,
black.
Oh yeah,
that was,
what was it?
It was it black and white was the original name of it,
but somebody already owned the copyright of that and they wouldn't sell it.
So then we had to switch it to black or white.
And it was like this trial about who should have the,
uh,
the rights to watch this kid that was,
was a racially mixed,
was half white and half black.
So black and white made it seem inclusive,
but we had to switch it to black or white.
So it kind of became like this make a decision kind of five to it.
But he let me,
I got to play a lawyer in that.
And,
um,
he had all these great dramatic scenes and all that.
So now I Kinda got a nice like acting thing going on where I get to do some
drama stuff.
I get to do some comedy stuff.
So it's been cool.
Yeah.
Okay.
Speaking of Cosmo magazine,
uh,
this,
next question is from Marcus Harbough.
I think as I said also from Facebook,
my wife thinks he's hilarious and she's generally not a fan of pro male types of
comedy.
How did he learn to so expertly delivered that kind of humor without alienating
his female audience?
I alienated a lot of females.
I do,
I ate,
I alienated issue people.
I alienated politically correct people.
Like they got like that thing where like,
you know,
this is the issue.
You're only allowed to have this thought on this issue.
I have zero sense of humor about this issue.
These are all the proper words.
These are all the,
if you use these bad,
if use these words,
this,
you're this.
If you use that,
they're very like,
it's hilarious cause they're progressive left using the exact same like Fox News
extreme right.
Did the exact same fucking lunatics.
I hate him.
I hate progressive left people.
And I generally speaking and the Fox News to the right that taken our,
those people,
those,
I can't even listen to them.
They're idiots.
Yeah.
They're like
both of them and they both have
both of them.
Heart is in the right place.
They just,
they're not doing it and they're doing it in this very stolen esque kind of way
of zero tolerance.
Oh yeah.
Um,
and what's funny to me is the right always gets that the left just cannot see
when they're doing it.
It's like you've become what the fuck you're fighting and you're annoying.
You're annoying.
So I mean,
I think that explains,
you know,
a little bit of the Trump shit,
like how that guy kind of came up with,
it's like you guys were ramming this shit down.
Like what's this is,
this is so fucked up.
If you just look at politics like Obama was a response to eight years of the
Bush people ramming it down your throat.
And he was response to eight years of Clinton people ramming it down their
throats.
And then 12 years before that,
yet Reagan and Bush,
both sides just can't present their shit.
They gotta be like fucking,
Ooh,
eh.
You know,
and it's all it does,
is it?
It causes
resentment and the,
if you look,
the pendulum just keeps swinging like further and further and people sound
fucking right now.
People sound crazy to me.
The side that I can't watch it.
It's like if anybody,
if anything,
but are you in the left gets in.
It's like,
it's going to be socialism.
This is going to be like communist Russia.
And if anybody right gets in,
it's like,
this is like Germany in 1935 every fucking time.
Just,
just go and just go and like this.
So I don't know,
like I just tried to just be like,
all right,
let's settle down.
Everybody fucking relaxed.
Get yourself sandwich.
Some of these things could be true,
some of them might not be true,
but like getting into this,
Eh,
you're not going to be able to think clearly and be able to make the right move
when you have to.
I,
I guess.
So what was it?
Do you deliberately at times tried to lose the audience?
Like push them to the breaking point and like there was something that I I and
then reel them back.
I mean,
is that what I used to do that was from playing hell rooms and no one would
listen.
So what I would do is I would make a statement that would make people be like,
dude,
what the fuck?
And thinking that I'm heading towards this thing.
Right?
Like I would make a statement that would make anything make you feel like I'm
heading towards like a supporting the clan or beating women or anything like
that.
You just say that and that gets everybody to drop their fork to listen.
They're like,
dude,
what the fuck is this?
And then you just wind it back to the point that you wanted to make anything.
Oh,
all right.
Okay.
That's kind of funny.
And then you just keep doing that.
And then eventually once I,
once I had that,
yeah,
once I had the room,
then I could just do my show and I think a little bit of that and started to
bleed into my style.
I don't know,
mean I don't do that anymore on purpose.
When I was coming up,
I used to do that on purpose.
There was all these techniques.
You could also start talking quieter if people talking louder.
People used to say that,
that never fucking worked for me,
that not just nobody heard me.
I'm just like,
okay,
nobody's listening to my job.
But you know,
yeah.
A lot of that came from,
um,
you know,
all the,
those crazy rooms I did and I'm very proud that I did all those and I didn't
sidestep any of those.
Like I pretty much did all of my,
did the,
uh,
the good Romans,
the bad room is the white rooms,
black rooms,
gay clubs.
I did everything because I really felt that I,
I know why.
Just I remember this.
I,
when I was a kid,
not a kid,
um,
I was like probably 18 years old and it was the summer of 86 and Rodney
Dangerfield lake,
great.
Rodney Dangerfield was on,
um,
he was on tour and he came to this place,
great woods.
Now it's called the tweeter center.
And I met him,
he came and he,
he killed and he was hilarious and all that.
And I saw all these people there,
blah,
blah.
And I didn't notice that they were all white because that was white.
So it was just like,
Oh wow,
we're all watching this guy,
whatever.
And then like,
like a month later I saw Eddie Murphy on the raw tour.
He had the blue leather suit,
I lawn seats.
That's how famous this dude was.
I was sitting on the grass watching guy doing standup comedy.
He had like the weather girls opened up for him and everything.
And I remember that night looking around going,
wait,
this guy's making everybody laugh.
This is the difference.
So I remembered one,
um,
getting into comedy that I,
I didn't want to be that guy,
like being like a radio station.
Like he makes white males 18 to 35,
you know,
like I want him to be like,
no,
this guy is funny.
But,
but the only way to do that was to do all of those,
uh,
those different rooms.
And I didn't,
it didn't always go well.
Um,
like black rooms are hilarious.
Like they,
it's like the more I learned about them is they're either,
they're having fun no matter what.
You're going to have fun with you
without you,
but either way they're going to have a good time.
So
that was definitely,
um,
those were some of my favorite shows that I ever did.
That was that there was a legendary show at this now gone comedy club that sound
like a fucking wine bar,
which just kills me because I mean it was just the raw,
just sick.
It's like in the village,
it was right as Giuliani was taken over,
some people was still selling drugs out in front of him.
It was crazy.
And I used to see like,
you know,
all these guys like young Dave Chappelle,
Jay Mohr,
Ali's bread,
Johnny in the Round Guy,
all these guys just stick,
just murdering in there.
But Sunday night was,
was the uptown show,
cause they wouldn't say,
you know,
the black only show,
I guess.
So they would say the uptown show and this guy,
uh,
um,
talent and,
and we'll still,
Vince used to host that show.
And that for me that was the show.
Like to this day,
like that was the most fun show I ever did was when,
when you killed on that show dude,
it was like you walked out of that,
why am I not famous shift?
Like that's how hard it was just everyone was on top of you.
It was the greatest ever.
But when you bombed it was just like,
why did I ever think I was funny?
I should have opened the hardware store.
You would just leave like the j those are some rough nights.
So going back to the,
uh,
technically one bedroom that was really a studio and getting under the Futon
just laying there.
Yeah.
A lot of grunt and Groan in the next day in the shower.
Like Ah,
God I hate myself.
You know.
What piece of advice would you give your 25 year old self?
Oh,
I hate that question.
Why are we saying,
if you could go back and tell yourself what you know now,
what did you dislike about your 25 year old self?
If you prefer that question.
Um,
what did I dislike?
No,
I definitely felt like a freak back then.
I definitely did not feel,
I never felt like I fit in anywhere until I went to a comedy club and just
seeing all the comics and I was just like,
these,
these people are the same kind of crazy than I am.
You know what I mean?
Like everybody's out of their mind.
But like they,
there was a specific way that they were nuts that like,
I just felt like,
yeah,
we just meet him.
Like I like,
I,
it's like I know this person,
but I don't know them.
Like they,
it just felt like I'm in a weird way.
Like you were going home.
It was crazy.
But as far as like what I would tell myself,
um,
I would be afraid to fuck it up cause it ended up so well,
you know,
it's like that,
uh,
back to the school.
But back to the future,
whatever the hell it's called,
um,
I always mess up the name of movies back to the future where it,
you change one thing and you know,
seeing all your mom wants to fuck Yo.
However that happened.
Wasn't that one of the storylines?
Calvin [inaudible] kill good family movie.
The mom wants to bang her son from the future.
Oh,
it's great for their kids.
It was wonderful.
How old are you now?
48 what do you think your 60 year old self would tell your current self?
Twice.
Some apartment buildings by some apartment though.
Yes,
because you're going to be,
I,
you know,
I know I want to do stuff like that because I want to,
when I'm 70,
I want to leave if I want to,
I probably won't because I love doing it so much,
but I don't want to be that guy in that mustard stain Tuxedo suit.
Just still,
he knows the numbers start going down the back nine.
And I'm like,
Oh,
you have things to say.
You know,
it's just people going like,
oh,
I saw him in front of like three people.
It was sad.
There was a donut making sheikh machine in the back.
I gotta go back to those gigs.
So I would like to,
uh,
not go out and,
you know,
I'm doing real well.
I'm making great money.
I would like to not go out and buy a bunch of dumb shiny shit.
I would like to buy shit like assets.
So I have money.
So my,
my next goal,
the same way I did the thing where I never got sucked so far into this business
where I do apologize if I was,
even if I wasn't sorry,
I,
um,
I now want to get the money that making this business to make money outside of
the business.
So because eventually this business is done with you.
Yeah.
It just is.
And you have to realize he got to deal with that shit.
So like,
I would just love to be,
to be honest with you,
man,
if I could just,
you know,
making a decent amount of money off of shit like that.
Yeah.
Just always picture myself just sitting on the back porch,
you know,
with a dog,
not giving a shit,
smoking a cigar.
Like that's how I want to,
what kind of stuff?
We still do stuff.
Uh,
oh,
they don't mess them up with global warming.
If he can still make a great one to definitely be a Cuban.
Um,
probably a reboot.
Stow the Cohibas I like,
I like the part of this.
I just smoke when recently,
I don't even know the name of it was one of the sickest cigars I uh,
I've ever smoked,
but it was like,
it was like a two hour smoke in a,
I absolutely love cigars,
but like,
you know,
there is a thing amongst cigar smokers where like if someone comes nosing
around,
you know,
if you break up,
you bust out like a box of cigars at a party,
all these fucking phoneys will come up.
Oh you want to go?
You smoke goes,
oh yeah,
I smoke cigars and you'll learn this one time you'll give out your cigars to
them and then what kills you is you'll look over like a half hour later and the
things like halfway smoked and they already asked the thing out of this now
snubbed the thing out.
And I learned that.
So I got a Bobby Kelly,
I shouldn't out him here.
I shouldn't have said his name.
He had surgery,
he has to fix it in post.
He has two humidors.
He's got the real shit.
And then he's got his bullshit.
So somebody comes over and be like,
so he just gave you like cigars?
Oh yeah.
What kind of,
what kind do you like it if they're just saying bullshit,
I got one for Ya.
I got one,
I wanted a carnival,
here you go.
So,
but I really like,
um,
smoking a cigar is a sacred thing to me.
Like if I have a great cigar,
like sometimes if there's no place to smoke,
I will not smoke it.
Like I'm not going to be this asshole,
these fucking,
a couple of my friends,
their animals,
they'll stand next to a dumpster.
Like it's not as cigarette smokers are animals.
They're like,
they're on the shit.
Right?
So there'll be in an alley they don't care fucking rat running by and they're
out there smoking,
catching pneumonia.
They're analysts.
Cigar smoking is a gentleman thing.
It's like,
it's some,
it's some brilliance in adult thing.
And so it's just like,
I want to be with people that I love telling stories,
hanging out and like the right,
the right everything.
And then,
and then even if you're doing it by yourself,
it's like you have to have,
I'm never doing this.
Like,
well can I,
can I smoke it before?
Blah Blah Blah.
It's like I would just want to have nothing and I just sit there in that great
guy thing that my wife could not understand is just being able to be a guy and
just be not thinking about shit.
I'll just be sitting there just enjoying yourself.
Next question's from sharpie sharp.
Uh,
I would like to see that birth certificate.
This is from Facebook.
Uh,
what's the best heckle that's been thrown your way or most memorable?
There's too many men.
Um,
all right,
well we'll go around.
We'll go around the,
uh,
all right.
When I was black room,
best one I ever got,
I was bombing at this place,
used to be called mixed nuts.
It's now called the comedy union mix.
And I was up there and do,
when I tell you five minutes to straight silence,
dry mouth,
nothing.
And it was the summertime when sound carries,
right?
And I am just
going and going and it's nothing and nothing.
And then just in the middle of one of my jokes,
a meandering in this long set up for something else that's going to bomb big
black lady in the back,
just out loud to nobody just sort of looked around this way.
I laughed yet
and the whole place exploded laughing and I didn't know how to deal with it.
I didn't know I had to address it.
I kept trying to do my material and then they were just laughing at me trying to
do,
man,
it was fucking humiliating.
I Dunno,
there's one,
uh,
I'll tell you the weirdest one.
I got,
um,
I've told this one before,
one of the weirdest ones I got,
I was a danger fields and doing the midnight show and it was just one of those
nights everybody was bombing in place was packed and nobody was laughing.
I remember the guy in front of me,
like he was just bombing so bad and he was in on some show where he played a
bartender and he had gotten beaten up.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
you guys see that movie he's trying to get,
you got to see this movie,
Blah Blah,
blah,
blah.
He goes,
yeah,
I played the bartender,
the,
you know,
the star of the movie,
beat the s,
you know,
beat the shit out of me.
You guys see that?
And then some kitting it back just goes,
he should have killed you.
So
it's like,
oh for that guy walked past me,
never even looked at me.
He just,
when he got off stage you can set this flop sweat and just walk by me,
just gone file.
Wow.
And then I went on stage,
immediately bombing and there was this group of kids in the corner,
these white dudes and they would just like just ready for a fight.
They were just super fucking hot set that whole,
my dad used to beat the shit out of me vibe and everything I had learned up to
that point was like,
Bill,
don't get into it with them.
I heard them talking and I was like,
don't say anything.
Don't say anything.
And then finally I just,
that's fucking thing when you're on stage as a comic,
you think like this,
and this is like some sort of like a fucking gun and bullets,
but it isn't.
It's just plastic shit.
And I just like,
I finally said,
I'll go,
hey,
you know what?
What's going on over there?
What do you,
what are you guys talking about?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
I can't remember what to say.
And this guy just finally it was just yelled out,
you know,
I had the beat goes,
anything that gives yells out,
he goes,
anything red in onstage is a faggot.
Right?
And it was the most childish Haeckel I ever got this back when like people
didn't freak out about that word.
You guys are like,
oh my God,
what does that say about gay people?
Vik this was straight people used it.
It just meant you were an asshole.
And so he said that,
I just remember like I didn't know what to do.
It's just like,
it was so fucking childish,
but I also know he was going to like beat the shit out of me.
So I just went like right back into my state.
Mike.
My act like this,
almost like a Codis joke.
You know this right here at the reaction to that is why you can never leave the
comedy clubs by the way.
Like,
cause that used to be a funny story,
but now because of like gay people said what that word makes us feel like now
everybody,
even if you say it and you say that somebody else said it to you,
it becomes this weird thing of like,
well does he advocate when he said,
but it just becomes all of that and it comes like context and all of that shit
to some,
well that's what he said.
Spend a few,
a handful more questions.
You mentioned helicopter parents,
helicopters,
helicopters.
Yes.
Let's talk about helicopters.
All right.
How did you,
how and why did you get into helicopters?
You just run
gamut of everything here.
Ah,
oh yeah.
Helicopters.
How did I get into that paranoia of living in California?
Okay.
Living in the La Basin,
enough conspiracy theory about nothing being behind the dollar,
uh,
robots coming and all that type of shit.
And this is place became really claustrophobic.
Well,
it's just like,
how the hell would I ever get out of here when the shit hits the fan?
How do you get Outta here?
Like even when it's working well,
it's still takes three hours just to get out of here.
Forget about some army getting shit and I was just thought,
you know,
up and out.
That's the way to go.
Learn how to fly a helicopter.
It when the zombies come,
you just started up and got,
got,
got.
Gunky just fly out.
Assuming you're finding a way that does not work.
If you ever see that in the movies where you just start the thing up and you're
hang,
you fly out like that.
I mean you can do that,
but you're going to fuck it up.
Like you got to let the,
the band,
they got like belts and stuff.
They've got to let those things stretch.
You got to lift the engine heat up and all that.
So anytime you see Rambo and those guys just jumping into blank holdings to
Camaro and he just,
I mean if zombies were coming,
I would definitely do that shit.
But I'd be going by the way like please don't let the belt snapped
and he just knows it down into one of those fucks sake one with you.
Just imagining the visual.
Uh,
it's just like a lawnmower.
Aj taken out zombies and the,
uh,
do you have other preparations?
Now this is spoken to someone so people think this is crazy.
Uh,
so in San Francisco and then in New York and got really into at one point went
off the deep end with prepping stuff like got really into it.
Like going to canneries for LDS.
You guys can look it up,
you can really go down the rabbit hole and some of you will spin out and get
tied up in the straight jacket.
Uh,
but I,
and I was being kind of lectured at how unreasonable it was and how silly it was
that I was getting water and gathering food and all this stuff just in,
we had
disaster.
It took us off the grid for seven days or more SF,
which happens fairly regularly and uh,
some editors were kind of making fun of me because I was writing at the time.
And then hurricane sandy hit New York and Lo and behold,
nobody was prepared.
Right.
So do you have,
besides the helicopter,
do you have other preparations?
Nope.
No,
and I,
and I don't own a helicopter either,
so it's pretty fucking useless.
No,
what it once was,
I went down that rabbit hole and you got to get gold coins and you've got to get
this powdered food and all that type of stuff.
And then somewhere along the line I was just like,
do I really want to survive this?
Do I really want to see what's next or do I want to be one of the people that
die?
And I realized now I want to be one of the people that die.
JFK Senate,
the living will envy the dead.
And it's true.
I don't want to start over again.
Some whole new society.
I remember doing a face to a bid on that so we just pick it up a rake.
Like these are the new rules and you just solve gathering around with you burlap
shirt with a string tied around it.
I know like I remember when the uh,
that,
that fat dude who's running North Korea,
right?
The boss's son who's trying way too hard to show that he's a bad ass was saying
he was going,
he had missiles aimed at La and everyone was panicking.
I was like,
perfect man.
I hope it's right at my house,
right in my house.
I hope I'm watching the UFC or football Sunday to sit in here,
Dan.
And it just vaporized who you don't want to be is the people up in Bakersfield
just outside of it.
You still get the radiation with the boils and shit and you're trying to get
teeth are falling out.
Fuck that.
I'm trying to figure out how to catch squirrels.
They have no desire to do any of that.
[inaudible]
hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Shopify.
I have known and loved to Shopify.
It just about forever.
Back in 2009 when they had something like eight or 10 employees,
now they have more than 2000 I helped them as an advisor to create,
build a business competition,
which is now the world's largest entrepreneurship competition and many readers
of my blog,
first time business owners have ended up making millions and millions of dollars
each,
many of them as side gigs to their full time jobs.
So the goal of the build a business competition is to get,
would be entrepreneurs to get off the couch and make things happen.
All you have to do is open a store on shop,
find,
starts selling,
and you can join in July or after July to be eligible to win.
What does winning mean?
You have to be one of the top performers,
top sellers in a given category and the prize.
The reward is an exclusive opportunity to learn from mentors and experts.
And in the past that has happened at places like the Gatsby castle where we had
Tony Robbins and Daymond John and Seth Goden and so on,
or on Necker island,
which is so Richard Branson's private island.
It's nuts and super,
super fun.
I'm also involved,
so there's a special offer for people listening to this show.
Go to shopify.com forward slash him and sign up for a free 30 day trial.
You will get all sorts of exclusive free video courses to help you along and to
get started,
including how to start a profitable drop shipping business with Corey Ferera.
We'll also get some goodies from me.
It's all free.
It's all exclusive.
People were listening to this podcast,
so check it out.
shopify.com forward slash him and remember to sign up for free.
30 Day trial visit says brought to you by fresh books,
man.
Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners of this podcast and readers of mind love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by more than 10 million people and can send
invoices,
track your time and get paid very,
very quickly,
which suits the needs of a lot of freelancers.
I left to [inaudible] condos and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts,
you can link your credit card and debit card.
So all the things you buy automatically appear in your fresh books in the right
category,
so on and so forth.
Makes taxes easy,
makes invoices easy,
it makes your life easier.
And also in fact,
I'd recommend a pdf.
Uh,
they didn't ask me to read this part by the way.
They'd put the other pdf awhile back called breaking the time barrier.
Subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week with a service business?
And the story in that Ebook,
it's pdf is the short answer's really,
really good.
So I think should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
check it out,
but also why not test out freshbooks?
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
Inter timferriss two rs and two ss in the,
how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very little tracking and it's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and tried out because it is a
very good product and I think you will find it simplifies your life.
Joy.